hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
lv and abv sorry aav
transfection platforms will shape the
future of gene therapy manufacturing
i am sabrina lemmons of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
miris for more information about our
sponsor
please visit their site at
nearestbio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
lisa coop application scientist at
nearest bio
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top
of your screen lisa you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the introduction and
thanks to everyone for tuning into our
webinar
on how lv and aab transfection platforms
will shape the future of gene therapy
manufacturing
at miros we strive to provide turnkey
tools and fantastic scientific support
always with the goal of enabling
researchers around the world as they
seek to understand
and improve the human condition
during this presentation i will provide
a brief overview of mirror's bio in our
core technologies
and we will discuss the transit vireson
products that we've developed for
lentivirus and adeno-associated virus
production
we will cover the critical parameters
mirus used to develop our lv and aav
kits as well as some key considerations
for choosing transit virus gen
for your viral vector platforms
including the flexibility
to use whichever have tuning three cells
vector sets and culture media you'd like
how high tiders lead to fewer production
runs to generate sufficient doses for
large patient populations
and how maris and virusgen will support
you from r d all the way through
commercialization
following this presentation we have a
couple quick polling questions for you
and then we will open the floor for q a
any and all questions are welcome so
please don't be shy i do look forward to
the discussion
mirror's file was formed in the
mid-1990s by three researchers at the
university of wisconsin-madison with a
passion for gene delivery
both in vivo and in vitro transit lt1
the first serum compatible dna
transfection region on the market was
launched in 1996
and is still one of our most widely used
products shortly after lt1 miras also
commercialized reagents for small
and large rna delivery in addition to
chemical transfection reagents
mirrors offers solutions for
electroporation with the ingenious
electroporation solution
and easy parador electroporation
instruments more application specific
products included at the transit pro
transfection reagent and the chocolate
high yield expression system for protein
production
our transit x2 dynamic delivery system
introduced in 2013
is perhaps the most broad spectrum
chemical reagent we offer
as it's designed for both dna and small
rna delivery
and performs well with a wide variety of
cell types and applications
including gene expression rnai and
crispr cast genome editing
the transit virus generations that we'll
talk about today was first introduced
in 2017 as research grade transat virus
gen select which is designed for
pre-clinical and early phase clinical
production
was introduced last year transit virus
gen gmp
and our virus gen lv and aav kits will
be available in early 2021
and those are the products we'll focus
on today
in conversations with researchers we
often get the question
what makes mirror's reagents different
so i'd like to take a moment to address
it
while many transfection formulations
utilize a cationic polymer polymer-like
pi
or liposomes like lipofectamine mirrors
formulations are non-liposomal mixtures
of both cationic lipids and polymers
which promote effective complex
formation to a broad spectrum of cells
our formulations also tend to be less
toxic than liposomal formulations
because they're less disruptive to the
cell membrane
and unlike pi based formulations nearest
reagents are effective for
delivery of multiple nucleic acids to a
wide range of cell types from many
different applications
i'd also like to add that mira strives
to provide the best support possible for
our customers
our scientific team is comprised of
world-class chemists and biologists
committed to finding those perfect
formulations and protocols
to streamline and improve
transaction-mediated applications
additionally we offer a technical
support team of r d and application
scientists that work closely with the
regions you're interested in so when you
reach out to us via phone email or web
chat
you immediately reach an expert that can
help you address your questions
on the spot
to summarize mirrors bio is a nucleic
acid delivery company dedicated to
enabling research with products for
general dna delivery and dna rna code
delivery
products for specific applications such
as viral vector production
and products that utilize alternate
strategies for transactions such as
electroporation
all with the goal of supporting any
delivery method
any nucleic acid for all cyber cell
biology applications
in our 25 year journey we've made some
friends along the way
mirs has over 30 trusted distribution
partners supporting over 40 countries
around the world in all major markets
if interested you can find our list of
international distributors at
mirrorsbio.com
forward slash contact forward such
distributors we also offer international
direct ordering to countries for which
we do not currently have a distributor
now that you know a bit more about miris
let's dive into our discussion on the
transit virus and regent as well as the
virus
in kits for lv and aav production
i'm sure it's no surprise that
supporting cell and gene therapies was
top of mind when developing a new
transaction reagent for lv and aav
production
as we all know lentivirus is often a
critical component of cell therapy
as shown in this example where patient
cells such as t lymphocytes or nk cells
are harvested and then genetically
engineered to express a protein such as
a chimeric antigen receptor or a car
the better enables the cell to detect
and eliminate cancer once expanded and
readministered
into the patient's body and no
associated virus
is commonly used in gene therapy where
the virus itself is the therapeutic as
it contains a corrected copy of a gene
which can be directly administered to
the patient
currently there are three cell therapies
and two gene therapies approved by the
fda
in 2017 novartis is camrya which is
designed to treat acute lymphoblastic
leukemia
and calcius cardo which is designed to
treat non-hodgkin's lymphoma
were introduced very recently in july of
2020 the fda approved kites to cardus
for treating relapsed or refractory
mental cell
lymphoma on the gene therapy therapy
side in 2017
spark therapeutics launched luxurina
which is directed at correcting
inherited retinal disease due to
mutations in rp-65
in 2019 avexis introduced ogensma an aav
based therapy designed to treat spinal
muscular atrophy
now each of these therapeutics is
groundbreaking and life-changing which
is why there's so much effort in this
field
which also guarantees that there'll be
many more to come
according to data recently published in
bioprocess international there are
currently more than a thousand cell and
gene therapies in development
this figure shows the projected cell and
gene therapy clinical trials through
2026
with actual numbers dating back to 2010.
the real take home here
is that these therapies are growing at
an unprecedented rate and it appears
that we are only at the beginning of
this curve in 2020.
this figure suggests that there will be
between 10 to 12
000 cell and gene therapy clinical
trials by 2026
the graph at right breaks down the
current product candidate pipeline and
highlights that lentivirus and aav
are the predominant viral vectors of
choice for these therapeutics
when designing a reagent to support cell
and gene therapy develop development
we had several goals in mind first we
knew that we needed a reagent
formulation that supported delivery of
multiple plasma dnas to hexels which is
the basis for lv and aav generation by a
transient transfection
beyond that we wanted to develop a
region that was best in class so to
speak
for not just lv or aav but for both
secondly we screened libraries of our
lipids and polymers for a combination
that promoted effective complex
formation for both adherent and
suspension cell types
as the formulation would then be able to
support large-scale lv and aav
production
in formats such as the isellus and
roller bottles as well as stir-tank
bioreactors
last but not least we knew we needed a
formulation that supported reproducible
and scalable virus production
ultimately our goal was to simplify the
viral vector development process by
delivering a formulation
that yielded more functional virus per
transfection to streamline processes and
reduce production costs
and the transit virus john is able to do
those things
the features of our transit by
restaurant formulation include superior
performance
selling and platform flexibility and
batch to batch reliability
more data on those points to come in
addition to a functional qc
virus-gen select shown here includes
release testing
and quality documentation to streamline
the process of raw material
qualification
to ensure a seamless transition from
discovery through large-scale
manufacturing
transit virus gene is chemically defined
and animal origin free
and there's no commercial license
required for r d or manufacturing use
bi-based reagents are the most commonly
used formulations in viral vector
manufacturing
which is really what sets the bar for
reagent development at miros
this data generated in suspension 293 f
cells cronin freestyle f-17 media
demonstrates that virus chin outperforms
both 25 kilo-dalton pdi
and pei pro from polyplus by generating
up to 10-fold higher functional titers
for lentivirus enough to four-fold
higher functional titers for aav
production
virus-gen has demonstrated in this
figure also strongly outperforms pei
formulations
in adherent tuning through t cells grown
and transfected in dmm plus 10
fps if you'd like more details about
these experiments please visit
our select page at www.nearestbio.com
forward slash select
in these next few sections we'll look
more closely at critical workflow
parameters that impact lentivirus and
aav expression levels
as well as how these factors guided
development of our lv and aav kits and
recommended protocols
this figure depicts the process we
followed when developing the virus in lv
and aav kits
the first step was scouring the
literature as a starting point for
development of candidate compounds
we then tested each of these potential
enhancers for performance in our
established lentivirus and aav
walls with transit virus 10. with the
most promising candidates we
investigated other critical parameters
including dna amount and cell density at
transfection for both adherent and
suspension cells
and with our final lv and aav systems we
also compared expression levels with
various sets of plasmids
various serum free cell culture medias
as well as different suspension 293
cell types
the first critical component we will
explore are the impacts of total dna and
cell density
at the time of transfection
these figures show a dna titration from
1 to 2 micrograms of total dna per ml of
culture
for both lv on the left and aav on the
right
we found that lentivirus production
without the lv enhancer the black bars
is higher when using 1.5 to 2 micrograms
of total dna
however only 1 microgram of dna is
needed when using the lv enhancer
this data also shows that the lv
enhancer boosts hiders three to five
fold over reagent alone conditions
for aav we found that 1.5 to 2
micrograms of total dna per milliculture
is optimal
with and without the enhancer and that
the optimal dna amount
will vary depending on the stereotype
and vector sets used
as shown by the red bars at right the
enhancer doubles aav production in all
conditions
this does bring up an important point
for platform development though
as the total dna requirement for optimal
expression may depend
on the interactions of several
components for this reason we highly
recommend running a dna titration with
your final vectors
cell and medias to determine the lowest
dna amount you can use for robust
expression
the south entity at transfection is
another commonly explored parameter
for lentivirus and aav production with
transit vibration alone meaning without
the enhancer
2 million cells per ml at transfection
was best
in contrast significantly higher titers
are observed when using the lv enhancer
the red bars at 4 million cells per ml
for aav
we see equivalently high titers at 2 and
3 million cells per ml
both with and without the enhancer again
it's a good idea to do a cell density
titration with your final cells
gene of interest containing vectors and
media to determine what is optimal
based on the data we just covered for
dna and cell density at transfection
here is the final protocol for the
virusgen lv kit
the day before transfection cells should
be split to ensure that they are
rapidly dividing at the time of
transfection on the day of transfection
dilute cells to 4 million cells per ml
form transfection complexes for the
protocol by combining
one microgram total dna and three
microliters transit virus gen per 1 ml
of total culture
incubate 10 to 15 minutes add complexes
to the cells and place cultures at 37
degrees shaking overnight
18 to 24 hours post transfection add the
lv enhancer to the cultures at about 10
of the total culture volume and 48 hours
post transfection
harvest your lentivirus from the
supernatants and assay as desired
for the aav kit the upfront work is
similar however cells should be diluted
to 2 million cells per ml for
transfection rather than 46 per ml
also the aav enhancer is included in the
complex formation solution
so there's no need to reopen the culture
post-transfection
at 72 hours post-transfection or
whatever times best per your aab
serotype harvest and purify or assay as
needed
using the protocols outlined in the
previous slide we again compared the
performance of virus gen
as well as the virustone lv and aav kits
to both 25 kilodalton pi and pi pro
and suspension 293 f cells in freestyle
f17 media
with the revised protocols and enhancers
our improvements over pa
based methods is another two to three
fold greater than what was achieved with
fire strength reagent alone
the next critical component we would
like to take a closer look at is vector
design
until recently most of our virus done
reagents and lv kit development work was
done
with three different packaging plasma
mixes
the first being the third generation
virus safe lentiviral packaging plasmids
from cell biolabs
as well as the second and third gen
hybrid mission lentivirus packaging mix
from sigma
and the third gen lv max packaging
plasmids from thermo
traditionally we saw highest tiders
using the mission packaging mix which
isn't unexpected
since there are fewer total plasmids to
transfect with that second therogen
hybrid system
however more recently we tested the p
old lv packaging and transfer plasmids
from aldeveron
and honestly we were blown away by their
performance here we see functional lv
titers nearing 1 billion tu per ml
which really raises the bar for
commercial plasmids and also begs the
question
what else does this improve do these
types of vectors enable the use of
less dna and reagent to good
equivalently high titers
in this next experiment we transfected
two and three f cells at four million
cells per ml
with total p old vector dna ranging from
0.5 micrograms per ml to 2 micrograms
per mil
with transit virus gen and the virus and
lv kit the black pars
show titers without the lv enhancer and
we see that while titres are still very
high at 1 microgram per ml
they do increase when using more dna
however when adding the lv enhancer post
transfection
the highest headers are achieved when
using 0.75
to 1 microgram total dna per ml this is
another nod toward doing a dna titration
with your final system as less dna may
be required when all components are
optimized together
here we compare performance of the
virustone lv kit against pi pro and pi
max from poly sciences
for lv expression using the pl vectors
in
xb283 cells growing in xb293 media
titers for all reagents are very high
however we still see
3.4 fold higher titers versus pi pro
and 5.4 higher titers versus pa max with
the transit virus 10 lb kit
over the last few years we've had
conversations with researchers
all over the world working to develop lv
and aav suspension platforms
what we've found is that many if not the
majority of groups are
using xp2 and 3 or viral production
cells from thermal
and there seems to be a shift away from
293 f cells due to concerns with
consistency
we also hear many different serum free
medias mentioned though there are also
commonalities there
which leads us to the next critical
culture components for
lv and aav expression cell culture media
and cell type
in this lentivirus expression experiment
we used the p old packaging vectors for
mild devrun
and a transfer plasmid expressing gfp to
compare performance of the virus and lv
kit to pi pro and pn max
xp293 cells were adapted for several
weeks prior to transfection
into xb293 expression media freestyle
f17 expression media
lv max production media and the balance
cd hector and three media from irvine
scientific
cells were then transfected with one
microgram total dna at four million
cells per ml
we found that the virustone lv kit
yielded three to seven
fold higher functional titers as
compared to pi pro and pa max
i'd also like to note that we've
repeated this experiment several times
and that trend is very consistent
another trend we see
overall is the highest lv expression
with the balanced cd media and xb293
medias
with slightly lower titers consistently
observed in freestyle f17 and the lvmax
media
we performed a similar experiment using
xb293 cells adapted to the same four
medias
however this time for aav2 gfp
expression
using the aav helper-free system from
agilent technologies
transaction complex is performed with
1.5 micrograms total dna and 3
microliters virus gen reagent per ml in
the aav complex formation solution and
enhancer
results show up to 17-fold increase in
aav titers over the pei-based
formulations
when using the vyrusian aav kit and
again we see highest overall titers with
the balance cd-293
and xb293 medias
for this next experiment we adapted
viral production or vp cells to our
suite of four medias and transfected for
aav2 gfp expression
as a control we can currently
transfected xb293 cells growing in xb2
and 3 media
there are a couple noteworthy
observations one we continue to see
great results with the virustrend aav
system
two titers with bp cells are fairly
similar to those obtained with xp293
cells
and three highest titers are again
obtained with the balanced cd media
another noteworthy point is that
expression with our control is at about
42 million tu per ml
which is very close to what we observed
at the previous experiment performed two
to three weeks earlier
this demonstrates consistent performance
over time which is always a really good
thing to see
now that we've gone through a slide or
two of data i'd like to highlight
considerations for selecting transit
virus gen for your viral vector platform
really it all comes back to this figure
here that predicts
between 10 to 12 000 cell and gene
therapy clinical trials by 2026.
if we think about what that really means
in terms of production volumes it's a
daunting concept
we'll walk through this a bit more but
it can take hundreds to thousands of
liters of aav
to generate a sufficient number of
functional viral particles for a single
patient dose
if multiplying that by tens of thousands
of trials and an even higher number of
patients
it begs the question of can we make
enough
as it turns out there are many people
asking that same question
in the last three to four years there
have been countless announcements by
large pharmaceutical companies
cmos and cdmos such as fujifilm paragon
lonza and bramer bio stating that they
plan to invest
hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in expanding their
infrastructure for cell and gene therapy
manufacturing
it's likely that much of the added
manufacturing space will be devoted to
gene therapy
and aab production given the typical
dosage requirements per patient
to explain the average cell therapy
requires between
10 to the eighth and 10 to the 10th
viral particles per patient
for cell therapies a virus is used to
transduce cells ex vivo and therefore
will never need to contend with the
patient's immune response
for gene therapy the average patient
patient dose requires
10 to the 11th to 10 to the 16th viral
particles to be effective
this is because the virus is directly
administered to the patient
and must affect the entire target organ
or system
in addition the virus will contend with
the patient's immune response
if we do the math and translate viral
particle requirements to the amount of
cell culture required to produce that
much virus
it becomes very evident that higher
titers are important
so let's do that math let's say that a
locally administered gene therapy
dose requires three times 10 to the 11th
viral genomes
and a systemic dose requires 5 x 10 to
the 15th viral genomes
we get roughly 3 times 10 to the 9th bg
per ml
from pei-based production and assuming
even just four times higher titers we
get about 1.2 times 10 to the 10th vd
per ml with virus gen
if we multiply that out we find that
greater than 1600 liters of aav culture
is needed to generate one systemic
patient dose using pei
when using virus gen that required
culture volume per systemic dose
drops to just over 400 liters
if we think about what higher titers
mean on the production side it's a
significant reduction
in material requirements when fewer
bioreactor runs and
far less media and costly gmp grade dna
is needed to generate a sufficient
amount of virus
it's also less hands-on time less
paperwork less time and expensive
manufacturing suites
and really in summary higher titers mean
more efficient use of time and materials
and an overall reduction in workflow
costs
i think we've established that higher
titers are a good thing
beyond high tiders what are the other
requirements for medical research in
pharma groups in the cell and gene
therapy space in terms of transfection
reagents
first they need a product that promises
consistent high tidal virus production
we need support for virus production in
both adherent and suspension cells
because all formats will be necessary to
meet the demands
we need a transfection region that will
be manufactured under ctmp
and scalable cost-conscious production
processes with a reasonable workflow is
critical
at mirrors we've worked very hard to
ensure that virus-gen reagents and our
prototype lv and aav kits
meet those demands
as i mentioned earlier in the talk
virustrend is designed to support you
from r d through commercialization our
research grade product is configured in
vials of up to 1.5 mils and is stera
filtered and functionally qc'd
transit virus gen select is designed to
support pre-clinical and early phase
clinical trials
and is dispensed at 30 ml per bottle
assays for sterility
bacterial endotoxin mycoplasma and
formulation identity are performed per
usp guidelines
on virus gen select and are reflected on
the cfa which we'll see in the next
slide
irisgen gmp reagent will be available in
early 2021 along with the lv and aav
enhancers
virusgen gmp will be a 150 mil dispense
which is sufficient for 50 liters of
transfection
and will also undergo the same quality
release testing as is performed on virus
gen select
all virustown reagents are identical in
formulation
ready to use chemically defined and
animal origin free
documentation provided with transit
virus gen select is shown here
and can also be found on the transit
virus gen select product page which is
shown below
to summarize the coo and tse bsu
documents state that transit virus gen
select
is chemically synthesized in the u.s and
that there is minimal risk of
contamination with bovine spongiform
encephalopathy or bse or transmissible
bovine encephalopathy or tse our
certificate of analysis
lists the quality control testing and
results used for release of the virus
gen select product
as mentioned before assays for
functionality sterility endotoxin and
microplasma are performed
with virus gen you can expect strong lot
to lot consistency
as is demonstrated by this data where we
compared lv and aav expression
in 293 f cells using four unique
production lots of transit virus gen
reagents
virus 10 is also unaffected by multiple
filtrations
in this experiment we compared alvin aav
expression
with an inventory vial of virustone as
well as virustime that have been
filtered once twice
or three times through a 0.2 micron
filter as you can see there is no change
in expression levels with additional
filtrations
if you're interested in testing either
the virus-general reagent or the
virus-gene lv or aav kit for evaluation
in your viral vector or production
platform we definitely want to enable
you to do so
so please visit our sample request
portal at
slash sample and mirrorsbio.com the
virus gem select from the large scale
protein or virus production section
once we receive and qualify your request
we will contact you to verify which
sample you'd like
if beta testing the lv or aav kits we'll
arrange a prep talk with you prior to
your evaluation of the kit to walk
through the protocol and address any
questions that you may have
you'll then receive and evaluate the
sample please note that we're here to
assist with any questions that you have
during that time so don't be shy
if you'd like to just discuss
preliminary results or need to
troubleshoot
following your evaluation we ask that
you send us feedback you do not need to
share any proprietary information
however we do want to know your thoughts
on the protocols and overall performance
of virus gen compared to your current
production system
going back to the very first slide the
title of our presentation
how will optimize lv and aav workflows
shape the future of cell and gene
therapy manufacturing
well with products like transit virus
gen that enable
high tidal antivirus in both suspension
and adherence cells for cell therapies
in high tide aav production and
suspension cells for gene therapies
more therapeutics can be developed and
more doses created
to treat more people ultimately these
transformative technologies
enable us all to deliver innovation
empower discovery and improve life
if you'd like to learn more about the
transit virus and reagents or kits
there are a number of resources at your
disposal the transit virus gen select
page
is shown here as is our sample request
portal as you can hopefully see
how the virus gen select is circled in
red there are also webinars and video
tutorials available
to you along with frequently asked
questions page you can also download the
virus gen brochure and documentation
from our website if you're interested
to summarize the transit virus gen
reagent and viruses lv and aav kits were
designed to offer
superior performance flexibility
reliability
and quality to certain gene therapy
researchers
virus gen is also ao free and requires
no commercial license for r d
or manufacturing use
irisgen will be available in three
production grades all identical in
formulation
ready to use and chemically defined so
one reagent formulation can be used for
all stages of iris production
transit virusgen ruo is functionally
qc'd and comes in vials ranging from 0.3
ml to 1.5 mils
as well as multi-packs of the 1.5 ml
configuration
transvirus gen select is designed to
support the preclinical and early phase
clinical stages
and is dispensed in 30 ml per bottle
which is sufficient for a 10 liter
transfection
transit virus and ru and select are
commercially available now and will
support viral vector platforms from
discovery to early phase clinical trials
the transit virus gen gmp reagent along
with the lv and aav enhancers
will be available in early 2021 and will
support late phase clinical trials and
commercial viral vector manufacturing
and we are beta testing the virus gen lv
and aav enhancers now so please let us
know if that's something you'd like to
explore
we sincerely thank you for taking time
to learn about mirrors bios transit
virus gen reagents and prototype
peristem
lv and aav kits you're welcome to
contact me at any point with questions
at the email address listed here
so bishop.com mirrorsbio.com you can
also contact our tech support team via
phone
email or live chat on our website we do
have a couple pulling questions for you
now
and then we look forward to further
discussion during q a
okay so i think everyone can see the
survey questions
hopefully but our first question for you
is what culture medium will you use
for your large-scale production process
we want you to select all that are
applying
hopefully everyone had a chance to
answer that
it gives you about 10 seconds your
results are
all right i'll be max the balance and
other medias
we've got a good distribution here
all right great thank you okay so then
we'll move on to the second survey
question
and that is what is the smallest scale
cell culture format
that you trust will translate to
equivalent large scale production
and for this we would like you just to
select one answer
all right looks like we didn't have a
ton of people answer these but a one
liter bioreactor
oh there we go okay we have more coming
in
excellent all right so it looks like
people are trusting
the bioreactors um and then maybe a
little bit less the amber systems
um so that is great very good to see all
right thanks so much for that
thank you alicia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located
to the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have
time for let's get started all right
so lisa the first question i have for
you is how much material
to do we receive for beta testing
the virus gen aav
kit when can i receive a kit for testing
okay great question um so the material
that we will send those that are beta
testing the virus gen aav
and um and lb kits will be sufficient
for one liter
of transfection and so what that
essentially means is
you'll receive three milliliters of the
virus gen transfection reagent and then
100 ml bottles of the virus and aav
complex formation solution and enhancer
if you're testing the aav kits
and for the lv kit it's two different
100 knob bottles one is the complex
formation solution
and the other is the lv enhancer that's
added 18 to 24 hours post transaction
so essentially yes sufficient material
for
one liter of transaction
thank you so our next question coming up
is how does the amount of dna required
compared
to pei pro or lv max kits
so ultimately the total amount of dna
required is going to depend
on a few things including the vector
sets
that are used the cells that are used in
likely even the media so that that final
system that you decide but that said
we typically recommend one microgram of
total dna per mole of culture
whereas other systems like the ld back
system require a higher dna amount
typically 2.5 micrograms of dna per mil
we also have feedback from customers
generating aav but they have to use
about half the total amount of dna with
virustrend as they do with
pei based formulations like pei pro
and so again like i always encourage
people to do those titrations
of dna amounts to make sure that they
have optimal production levels
but typically with our reagents in
particular we
particularly when using enhancers
that one microgram per mil is pretty
safe
awesome thank you alicia our next
question
is how do enhancers increase viral
production
that's a good question and we see that
question quite a bit
it is our belief that the the enhancers
have a stimulatory impact on the cells
themselves which allow them to increase
production of the viral components
we know that the enhancers don't impact
the transfection part so they don't
increase endocytosis or the ability of
the cell to to bring in different size
transfection complexes because we've
tested addition at various time points
for the lv enhancer in fact we add that
both transactions are definitely not
impacting transaction there but the aav
enhancer we've tested
timing of addition of the enhancer
components
um anywhere from zero to 24 hours post
transfection and we see that boost
regardless so it's not transfection that
it's impacting it's the it's the cells
that it's impacting
thank you um and our next question
coming in
what kind of support can you offer if we
evaluate your products
right um so merits really does strive to
provide
excellent customer service and so if
you're evaluating
firestone for large-scale formats or one
of the
the kits so lv or aav what we like to do
is schedule a prep talk with you i think
we mentioned that in the presentation
um before you evaluate and so we'll walk
through the protocol we'll talk about
the different
um factors that you may want to optimize
with your specific sets we can go
through the data that we have
obviously we showed quite a bit of data
here today but we have
a lot more right our r t team has
generated a lot of data and
we can share that with you but really
we're there to answer any questions that
you have
and help you troubleshoot if that's
needed later on
and the aav and lv enhancer material is
not yet a commercial product
but if you if you evaluate that and it's
something that you want to move forward
with
um then we'll definitely talk about
making sure that you have that
to continue developing uh your
large-scale process so really
i think the take on that just mirrors is
here to support you so make sure that
you utilize us you know ask questions
um yeah i'd say that about sums it up
great thank you our next question from
one of our audience members
how do you culture the viruses in the
suspensions and what is the incubation
time and what is the protocol of use of
suspension media
okay um so for producing lv and aav and
suspension cells the protocol is a
little bit
um different for each virus type so i
guess i'll go individually
from lentivirus we would recommend you
know doing the transfection
adding the enhancer at uh 18 to 24 hours
post transfection and then the harvest
is earlier so
it's 48 hours post transfection so just
a day after you're adding
that enhancer to the cell and to harvest
antivirus it's you essentially just
collect the supernatant because the
virus
um is if you leak out of the cells into
the soup so you'll collect that and
purify from there
for aav it's going to depend a bit on
the stereotype that you're working with
so we know that some stereotypes can be
harvested as early as 48 hours
some of them are maintained within the
cell some of them are secreted
and so you just have to know the
characteristics of the stereotype you're
working with but
typically as our protocol spells it out
we would recommend
doing the transfection incubating at 37
degrees
and then harvesting your aav at 72 hours
post transfection and a lot of the aavs
are contained within the cells
and so you'll need to lyse the cells
through various methods it could be
freeze bath you're at a smaller scale
or a detergent based lysis if you're at
a larger scale
and then you would harvest according to
whichever process
that you're using
thank you our next one coming in what
stereotypes have been tested with the
virusgen
aav kit
okay um so at mirrors we have tested
um aav2 primarily um and so a lot of the
data that you saw there is is the aav2
gfp
from agilent that we've been using but
we have customers that are testing and
numerous other
stereotypes including so aav2 is common
5 6 8 and 9 are also quite common and so
we've seen
folks testing across those as well as
those that have um specialized or
proprietary capsids
for many different aav stereotypes
thank you i want to thank the audience
for all of our questions coming in the
next one
is what are the challenges faced while
developing
uh recombinant lv and aav for gene
therapies
so there are i think there's many
challenges in developing these types of
products
from the production side it's you know
there's there's a lot of choices to make
right you have to choose the right cells
the right media
and find that right platform that gives
you the highest possible
functional titers for production
and then scaling is another concern that
we hear a lot from other
other pd teams that's one of the
questions one of the polling questions
what size do you trust for for scaling
and so
we see people testing a lot in the amber
systems and we see people testing a lot
you know they'll start in shake blasts
and then move into the one liter or two
liter bioreactors
because they want to know that it scales
you know if it works great in a small
format is it going to continue to work
great is it scalable for our gmp process
so there are all of those bits of the
workflow to consider
and of course when it comes to the
regulatory side of things
if you're in a gmp process there is a
lot of paperwork so you need to know
that you're
qualifying every component that goes
into your system
every process that is used is very
heavily documented
and yeah and so the regulatory side is a
whole different ballgame but essentially
just
a lot you have to cover a lot of those
spaces
um yeah so i would say from start to
finish a lot of hurdles but
these are being developed rapidly by a
lot of people and so all these things
are being
worked out too
thank you our next question do you have
an assay for detecting
detecting residual virus gen
reagent
that is something that we are actually
working on right now so we are
working with charles rivers laboratories
to develop the residual reagents
detection assay and that is something
we'll have
likely later this fall and certainly
available at the time of a product
launch
so yes we will have that and it's
something that you'll be able to
you know send your virus to a company
they will run the essay and make sure
that it's cleared from the final product
okay we have time for one more question
um this viewer says i am in sierra
working in a veterinary lab how will i
get your products if i need them
great question um and so
we have um distribution partners around
the world and if
we don't support any specific country
then we will talk about whether a
distributor that is close to you
is able to support shipping a product to
you or we can talk about just
direct shipping as well so definitely
contact us
and we will talk about all of those
options
because we want to enable people to test
these tips obviously
thank you so much lisha i want to remind
our audience that those questions we
were unable to answer today and those
that come in during the on-demand period
will be answered by our speaker via the
email address
you provided at the time of registration
thank you again lisa do you have any
final comments for our audience
uh yes i guess i would just like to
thank lawrence for the opportunity to
share our viral vector reagent
development journey
with everyone that's listening and of
course um nearest would like to thank
everyone that participated today by
you know listening in and asking
questions and thanks in advance to those
that listen later to the
on-demand webinar um we really
appreciate your interest
in turns at virusgen and the enhancer
kits and we truly look forward to
working with you and supporting you as
you were to develop your own lv and aad
workflows so
thanks again everyone we really
appreciate your time
thank you so much lisa before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
again uh questions that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you protect
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank lisha
for her time today and her important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miris for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
that is all for now until next time
thank you everybody goodbye